what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel Richard on data this is my data
science statistics tutorial series where
I give you all the applied statistics
knowledge that you need to conquer the
data science world so in my last video I
talked about measures of center the mean
the median and the mode these are all
ways we can describe the central
tendency of a variable however in real
life it's often not enough to do that
you need to describe the spread of a
variable
maybe the uncertainty of some kind of
estimate and generally just describing
and reducing uncertainty and spread that
is the foundation for an awful lot of
applied statistics make sure you watch
this video to the end because I'm gonna
go over five different metrics
that's range interquartile range mean
absolute deviation standard deviation
and variance I'm gonna talk about how
you calculate these things how they
generally manifest and show up in
practice and then some of the awesome
intuition and properties behind standard
deviation and variance before I do that
though smash the like button hit the
subscribe button and then hit the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a new video all
right so let's start with a small amount
of data now let's just pretend these are
temperatures in the month of March in
Detroit we're gonna do that because I
like weather and because the weather
here gets really really weird sometimes
you're gonna see the data down below on
the screen and yes I exaggerated these a
little bit but only barely let's start
with a few summary metrics here so the
mean is 43.8 going down the list a
little bit you've got a minimum of 15
you've got a 25th percentile or 25th
quantile also known as the first
quartile that's 30 2.25 the median is 43
the 75th percentile is 55 point two five
and the max is seventy one right away
all those numbers except for the mean
that's just always a nice to have
or a metric those other numbers together
comprise your five number summary and
you can tell from looking at these right
away you already have a pretty
reasonable feel for the distribution of
this data and the general spread and
shape of it but then if you take your
minimum that's 15 and your maximum 71
then you take the difference between
them you get 56 and that's your range
now this number is not incredibly useful
in practice because if you think about a
real-world variable in a real world data
set you're gonna have a lot of outliers
on both ends so practically if you're
just taking the difference between the
maximum and the minimum
you're just taking the difference
between whatever the most extreme
outliers you have on either side are so
it's a nice to know thing it's probably
not something you're gonna end up using
and practice a whole lot though but
let's go back to the twenty-fifth
percentile and the 75th percentile
though so remember those are thirty two
point two five and fifty five point two
five and the difference between them is
twenty-three now that difference between
q1 and q3 that is the interquartile
range now this is a bit better of a
descriptor of the variability of your
data than the ranges because already you
have some kind of intuition and feeling
for what the middle 50% of your data
behave like it also has a nice practical
property because if you take the formula
twenty-fifth percentile minus 1.5 times
IQR that gives you the lower end cutoff
for outliers in the data set or at least
it's one way that outliers can be
defined similarly if you take the 75th
percentile or q3 plus 1.5 times
interquartile range that gives you the
threshold for outliers on the high side
so just another nice property and it's a
nice way in which interquartile range
can actually get used and practice and
be meaningful next I'm going to tell you
about a metric you've probably never
even heard of before and that's called
the mean absolute deviation and it is
calculated pretty much exactly like how
its
so you're gonna take the deviation or
the difference between every single data
point and the mean so if you take the
low end point here 15 the mean is forty
three point eight the deviation or
difference between those two
it's just twenty eight point eight the
direction doesn't matter because we're
just taking the absolute value here
you're gonna take every single one of
those deviations or differences and take
the average of all those that is called
the main absolute deviation and it's
fourteen point one in this particular
set of data more on this in a little bit
next one is the one everybody's heard of
before at least and that's the standard
deviation now this one is actually very
similar to the main absolute deviation
but it's the one everybody uses in
practice and this one is interpreted
basically as approximately the average
distance that an observation is from the
mean and the way this is calculated is
somewhat similar but different how it's
actually calculated is you take every
distance an observation is from the main
you square it then you add all those
squared deviations up you have a sum of
squares you take the square root of that
and then divide by n minus one now on a
technical note there's actually a
difference between what's called the
population standard deviation and the
sample standard deviation in the
population version we divide by n in the
denominator in the sample version we
divide by n minus one in the denominator
there's not really a practical
difference between these two very often
the difference is for mathematical
reasons but usually we'll use the N
minus 1 or the sample version because we
don't have a full populations worth of
data we have just a samples worth of
data now there's actually a real
practical benefit to us using the
standard deviation instead of the main
absolute deviation which we almost
always do in practice and that's because
with the standard deviation we're
squaring a whole bunch of things and we
add them up we create a sum of squares
eventually we take a square root but
that process of squaring things by
definition when you square things you
are making things bigger you're creating
more deviation you're creating more
distance the process of doing that
actually penalizes outliers more and if
you have a lot of outliers you end up
seeing a much bigger gap between the
standard deviation and what the main
absolute deviation would be so if you
take our example from before the mean
absolute deviation was 14 point 1 but
the standard deviation is seventeen
point three so just keep this in mind
the mean absolute deviation is a little
bit sensitive to outliers the standard
deviation significantly more so and a
lot of practical applied statistics and
data science work it can really Center
on reducing variability reducing
variance reducing the standard deviation
what have you so I hope this really goes
to illustrate the impact that outliers
can have and sometimes when that's your
goal of reducing uncertainty or reducing
variation outliers are the very first
thing that you want to think about last
but not least we have variance so this
actually gets misused in people's
language a lot variance is actually a
very specific statistical term sometimes
it can be used interchangeably by people
with variation or variability which are
more of these general terms which
describe the spread or uncertainty about
your data no don't use those
interchangeably with variance because
variance is a very specific term
variance does not have a super intuitive
definition it's approximately the
average squared distance that an
observation is away from the mean it's
calculated by very similarly to what we
did with the standard deviation we take
every observation subtract it from the
mean square that and add all those
squared differences up then divide by n
minus 1 the only difference is in the
numerator we're not taking a square root
anymore they're often going to see
instead of the standard deviation used
alongside the mean to describe a
statistical distribution now this is
just because it has really awesome
mathematical properties it's also known
as the second moment of a distribution
and the same property as before with the
standard deviation applies with the
sample variance versus the population
variance so in practice of all the
metrics I've just described
you're going to see the standard
deviation manifest a lot more than any
of the others most of the time and just
really notice from that one number the
standard deviation look how much more
information than just the mean alone you
have about that one variable again
you're getting all this more information
about what the data look like from only
one number standard deviation and
variance form the mathematical backbone
of statistics because almost all of
statistics really does come down to
quantifying how uncertain or how
unlikely some particular event is
statistics is the science for that and
these are really just the building
blocks for that science I really can't
stress enough so much of practical
applied data science comes down to
reducing or eliminating uncertainty so I
really hope this provided some intuition
behind that and just help to provide
some helpful food for thought so thanks
for watching this video until next time
Richard on data